c'est sans doute le restaurant le plus
sûr de new york
ces tables sont sans cesse désinfecter
elles sont espacés l'une de l'autre
le nombre de clients est limitée au
quart de la capacité et le masque est
obligatoire
jusque là rien d'anormal ces règles
sanitaires sont imposés par les
autorités publiques
là où le city winery se distingue c'est
que pour y entrer il faut montrer patte
blanche
chaque client doit se soumettre à un
test de dépistage de covè 19 un test
rapide près en 15 minutes
notre but dit-il est d'encourager les
gens à se faire tester de plus souvent
possible
personne n'y échappe ni les employés ni
le patron ni les journalistes
reportage ni les enfants par ce mythe 9
ans étaient très nerveux sont attendant
sans résultat terrifiée à l'idée de
contaminer ses grands parents son
résultat négatif est reçu comme un grand
soulagement pour le propriétaire du
restaurant
il s'agit de s'assurer que ceux qui
entrent dans la salle à manger
ce rang le plus en sécurité possible un
argument qui a convaincu bien des
clients
je pense que c'est une idée géniale 10h
à carbonne
ici pas de files d'attentes et c'est
avec un verre de champagne à la main
gracieuseté de la maison que les clients
comme sacha attend des résultats
le test n'est pas gratuit chaque client
doit débourser 50 dollars pas donné mais
de l'argent bien dépensé selon carla
bamboo ça si on écrit à dépenser 20 $
pour un cocktail
pourquoi ne pas payer 50 pour un test de
modèles selon le patron du restaurant le
principal atout de ce genre de test
c'est qu'il permet d'attraper des gens
qui sont comptait jeu sans le savoir car
en temps normal dit il ce les gens qui
ont des symptômes se font tester si plus
de restaurants voit-elle pas selon lui
cela permettrait de freiner la contagion
mais pour michael gough ces tests ont
d'abord et avant tout une tentative de
sauver son restaurant durement touché
par la pandémie
son chiffre d'affaires a baissé de 90%
par rapport à l'an dernier
ce revers est alors que les autorités de
new york veulent fermer les restaurants
et les bars ils espèrent encore
convaincre qu'il y a d'autres solutions
one shot online tout accord s'il s'agit
d'abord de protéger les clients et
d'empêcher les restaurants fermés
l'expérience vise aussi à démocratiser
les tests de dépistage avec un message
aux autorités publiques d'ici à ce que
tout le monde soit vacciné les tests
représentent un bon moyen de conserver
un semblant de vie normale et peut-être
aussi de protéger toute une industrie et
pour tous ceux qui se posaient la
question oui nos tests de dépistage se
sont tous révélés négatifs
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
new york